Oh man, it's Bill Belichick's house
Aw cool, Super Bowl rings!
Hey, guys, look! I'm Bill Russell Wilson!
Jameis, what are you doing?
Get back here
C'mon Matt, it's just a little QB sneak
Huh, guys I don't know about this...
Can't believe how easy it was to sneak in here
I know. It's like getting through your
offensive line
Heyyy...
Whoa, check it out!
What the...?
He's got a clone army of...
Gronks
No wonder he's playing every week
Goodell needs to know about this
Shall I intercept them, Mr. Belichick?
Yes Malcolm
What is all this?
It's like some sort of new play or something
Oh shi...
Aaaaah!!! KILL KILL KILL!
I see you gentlemen have found my latest cheat
The human centerpede
You see, Tom is getting old and needs
extra protection
Genius
He can take snaps from shotgun and still
be under center
You've gone too far, Belichick!
Too bad there's nobody who can stop me
Oh there you guys are!
Sorry I'm late. I took a lot of sacks
Aaahhhh my kryptonite, Eli Manning!!!!